hola a todos en este y en los próximos
vídeos hablaré de lo que son los planos
tangentes muy bien vamos a hablar de
planos tangentes pero no vamos a hablar
de planos tangentes en cualquier
contexto sino solo vamos a hablar de
estos planos tangentes de las gráficas
gráficas de funciones porque quizás en
alguno de tus cursos que estés llevando
de cálculo quizás estén incluso hablando
de planos tangentes a superficies
parametrizados verdad aquí no aquí vamos
a restringir nos al caso de las gráficas
de funciones y quizás sea bueno comenzar
con el caso de una variable verdad
cuando nosotros tenemos una función de
una variable con una sola salida verdad
si nosotros tenemos digamos esta es la
gráfica de la función y nos fijamos en
este punto particular entonces podríamos
pensar en la línea tangente es verdad a
la gráfica y qué pasa justamente por ese
punto es decir aquí cerquita de este
punto pues podríamos aproximar muy bien
esta función con esta línea
entonces la idea es esencialmente la
misma en el mundo de varias variables de
hecho es algo muy similar en términos de
la intuición geométrica de hecho es casi
idéntico verdad tenemos cierto tipo de
gráfica de una función como la que
tenemos aquí y en lugar de tener una
línea tangente verdad porque la línea es
en una dimensión y aquí queremos algo
como en dos dimensiones verdad que es
una superficie entonces en vez de una
línea vamos a tener un plano tangente y
esto es algo que va a estar apenas
tocando en un punto en particular a la
gráfica verdad entonces justamente eso
es análogo al caso de la línea tangente
que apenas toca la gráfica de la función
en el caso de una dimensión verdad y
podría estar digamos está definido en
distintos puntos no solo en un único en
particular verdad podríamos mover este
plano justamente que esté tocando apenas
a la gráfica de la función pero podría
estarlo tocando en puntos distintos
verdad y usualmente el primer paso para
abordar este problema es pensando en el
punto en donde queremos evaluar verdad
estamos pensando quizás por ejemplo en
él
de una dimensión en el punto x 0 verdad
y pensamos en la gráfica de una función
que sea lineal verdad y que apenas toque
a la gráfica en este punto verdad y que
sea de forma tangente en el mundo de las
varias variables verdad vamos a elegir
un punto de entrada digamos como este
punto rojo de por aquí verdad y
podríamos incluso tomar varios puntos
distintos verdad en no no tienen por qué
ser exactamente donde yo lo había puesto
podríamos imaginar poniéndolo en
cualquier otro lado una vez que hemos
decidido qué punto de entrada tomar
veremos cuál es donde se encuentra sobre
la gráfica es decir cuál es el valor que
tiene bajo la función verdad así que en
este caso esto más o menos se ve que
toma el valor de cero en este punto así
que la salida de esta función sería cero
verdad ahora lo que queremos es un plano
que sea tangente justo en ese punto y
vamos a dibujar una especie de plano que
sea tangente justo por aquí verdad y si
pensamos en lo que este punto representa
en realidad ya no es un solo x sub 0
verdad
tenemos una una entrada de varias
variables entonces en lugar de tener x
sub 0 vamos a tener x 0,0 verdad va a
ser una variable muy multidimensional de
entrada y el objetivo principal aquí
será hallar una nueva función que vamos
a escribirlas y digamos by va a ser
encontrar una nueva función el que por
supuesto dependa de nuestro punto x en
donde nos interesa verdad y que quizás
dependa de nuestra función efe aquí
también podríamos poner la dependencia
respecto al punto inicial verdad el x 0
y es cero pero el punto es que esta
función debe ser tal que su gráfica sea
exactamente el plano que estamos
pensando verdad el plano tangente a la
gráfica de la función original
efe y en los próximos vídeos vamos a
hablar de cómo calcular esta función y
en principio podría parecer bastante
intimidante el pensar en controlar un
plano en tres dimensiones pero en
realidad es muy parecido al caso de una
sola variable bueno nos vemos en el
próximo vídeo